america's trusted media to the uh to
report the news fully accurately and
fairly has etched down four percent
points to last year's 36 percent making
this year's
reading the second lowest in gallup's
trend in all seven percent of all u.s
adults say they have a great deal and a
29 percent a fair amount of trust and
confidence in newspapers television and
radio news reporting which combines four
points about 32
which uh record low in 2016 amid the
divisive presidential campaign between
trump and hillary clinton in addition 29
public uh currently registers not very
much trust uh and 34 have not at all so
meaning
to simplify this math they confuse the
out of everybody 36
trusts the rest do not trust 1972 in
1976 68 to 72 percent of americans
expressed trust in the mass media that's
a pretty crazy number 72 and 76
nearly 70 percent of americans trusted
the media yet by 1997 when the question
was next asked the trust had dropped to
53 percent
in 20 years it dropped 20 percent
trusted immediate media which has
averaged 45 since 19 1997 has not
reached a majority level since 2003.
guys 36 it's a scary thought to think
the number right now i mean do you trust
the media do you trust the media
if yes who do you trust in the media who
is today's cronkite that you follow in
the media this is well i think it's not
good this is 1972. yeah i'll just kick
this off the the it's this is good and
bad i'll give you the good the good the
bad the i'll get the good
or the bad is that in 1972 you had
three major outlets right you had the
big three cbs nbc abc
okay
we all about choice here all right so
then fox showed up we're not all of us
some people cnn showed up
um
ted turner a fan of the show um
and then obviously
boom the cat was out the bag you have i
mean back in the day when when we were
growing up how many channels were on tv
10 20 30 at the most now there's
literally a thousand so options go lower
so the point is this is now you can go
live in your own echo chamber you can go
to your breitbart and that's where you
get your news or you can go to your
msnbc and that's where you get your news
or you can go to whatever you
are getting your your confirmation bias
and you can just get your news there
the options are good the different media
outlets are good but the fact like this
is we say this all the time
i'll watch fox i don't like tucker but
i'll watch tucker
i don't love
everything that's on fox news i'll watch
it though i watch cnn i watch nbc i get
my information from multiple sources
like you always say is find something
you agree with now go find the exact
opposite thing and that'll enhance your
argument but i wish my my final point is
here i wish we'd get to a point where at
least there's some
agreement on facts right now it's just i
think there should be disclaimers this
is an opinion show hannity should be an
opinion show don lemon should be a
opinion show that's not news
five o'clock news or even the five
that's all opinions so that that's
there's the good the bad and the ugly of
this i think there should be a
disclaimer if it's opinion versus actual
news i don't even know what is actually
the problem is that the fact checkers do
we even trust them
there's that part we thought by fact
checking that we could trust what the
media or whoever is saying
we're
who do you trust myself i trust myself
no seriously i trust myself to be able
to do the research and actually be a
free thinker on a lot of these topics
and actually raise my freaking hand and
say you know what i wasn't right
and i think what's happening right now
is that some people are realizing man
i used to watch this show and then i
realized they're full of
and then i watched this show and i
realized the same thing so it's better
that i do both and i you know decipher
and use discernment and figure this out
but until we get to the point where
people can be called out on both sides
and and actually come like when you said
and actually say a spade is a spade and
then people gerard you really had a good
point the other day you and i were just
talking about this briefly and uh you
know people will see a spade and then
they're like nah i still ain't gonna
accept this and i think that's the
problem
you know like even with the world the
way it is i mean we have a you know
we're talking malkovit and stuff it's
like the survival rate is so good right
now we should be celebrating
not acting like
we're in doom and gloom
you know and it's just the way that the
the echo chambers are you know and they
just want to say what they want to say
well i mean there's two things two
stories that we didn't get to cover
today but that'll that'll explain kind
of why that is that way right there's
china appears set to ban reporting by
news outlets not directly funded by the
communist party and there's also katie
cure coming out and admitting that she
buried uh ruth bader ginsburg story on
uh
you know ruth bader ginsburg was very
very uh adamant that the players
shouldn't kneel she was very uh
boisterous in her disappointment in
colin kaepernick and katie corey
admitted kitty kirk admitted to burying
that story because she thought it would
be a bad look for
ruth bader ginsburg so she again that's
not reporting the news that's
manipulation that's social engineering
the 35 people who trust the news right
now you guys are wrong
the the trust in our news should be zero
it doesn't mean you shouldn't listen it
means you shouldn't trust okay you let
you hear tucker cross you say all right
that makes sense this doesn't make sense
and then like you guys said you go find
a second and third now pat i have one
request from you if you do buy that
media company if you do buy that print
overt bias whoever they are
they don't get to hide behind this guys
of journalism they don't get to hide
behind this guise of objectivity it's
gone it's over overt bias all right two
things whatever they're registered or
whoever whatever politicians they've
donated to has to be in their byline
anderson cooper registered democrat
donated xyz
then whatever they say has we can
understand that it's coming from that
perspective the other thing is user
interaction if you get a story the user
should be able to go
to to point to to click right or left 78
percent of readers said that this is a
right-leaning article 72 percent of
readers said this is a left-wing that's
the plan that's the plan actually what
we want to do but i think uh the current
state of things in the media panepticon
it's a little bit of a
yes
it's it's a little challenge do anything
that's the word of the day
try to use it ten times today
don't call your mom just to say what do
you think about this
i talked you talked to he left me a
message about pinocchio and that's
speaking of
i gotta i got a text message from my mom
uh this morning goes why'd you lose my
number
he's giving you that jewelry i gotta
call you i gotta call you mom my bad can
i can i we probably gotta wrap up i'm
gonna say one thing about the the china
and everything with that yeah when i was
at that freedom forum the other day
there's a something called the firewall
project where they'll they'll side by
side
they will put up google and then what
google is in china and they'll let you
look an image
of uh something in america and then show
you what they show in china and it's
completely
different you talk about propaganda or
brainwashing like so for instance you've
seen the uh you'll probably appreciate
this you've seen the image of she
next to winnie the pooh you've seen that
he kind of looks like him a little bit
so if you do that in the american google
it pops right up you put that in china
zero percent will that pop up zero
percent i mean you can try it right now
she winnie the pooh i'm sure you'll get
this thing right boom
zero images of that in china and then we
went on and on and on and on of
different like even with trump with
trump in america
um
they'll they'll be
the good the bad the ugly of trump
images like
all the images in china where comb over
flying over evil you know fire and fury
it's just
china's
though control something in america and
then duckduckgo it and see how different
the results you get 10 seconds guys so
i'm glad you brought that point up
fantastic
now i got to get that image out of my
head with xi and we need to pull all day
today
but anyways i don't think
can't hear anybody david's censoring you
david is answering you go ahead just
usually save the panopticon and then
yeah
keep using our word so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye
[Music]